we actually met yes and Mr Daniel was in
the room with me and I remember yeah yes
did your mom pass
yeah oh my God she says it still feels
like yesterday that I died
oh my God she says his faith needs to be
restored again
do you understand that
but you're your dad I don't know did you
have like a a kind of a separation with
your dad or was there a little uh
because your your mom your dad showed me
there was like a lot of ups and downs
with our relationship
and he says in through and your father
just sets me through your gift I was
able to let my son know how much I do
love him and how proud I always have
been of him and I am sorry that I was
not able to show him the love that he
deserved from me and now I see your mom
is like hitting him
says you know
Jesus you sometimes think that you hear
her call your name
I I because I feel like and again like
it's how I hear spirit so it could be
for you however you think that you hear
it so know that that is your mom
because I don't know if you've had the
dreams or like the visitations because
she goes I've tried to show my son
several times how healthy and beautiful
I look
she do you have your mom's eyes
because she had me look right in her
eyes and she says my son carries my soul
and my eyes with him every day
do you feel her like driving with you or
like if you're on the train or like you
feel like she's always behind you
sometimes I can really like feel her in
know that that's her soul it's almost
like I feel like your mom is trying to
give your soul a hug
your mom wants you to actually picture
her perfectly healthy with the suitcase
open at the bottom of her feet she would
like you to put in this suitcase all of
the negative emotions anything that is
making you feel bad or sad about
yourself or that is not giving you the
ability to heal I need you to put into
the suitcase and close it up and she
says and hand it back to me with love
but more importantly Faith she says I
need you my Danny Boy to have faith
oh
okay
[Applause]
your mom just said just hold him a
little bit tighter
did your mom have a thing with her hands
because she goes tell my son how young
my hands look I don't know why
has never told me to talk about how
young their hands look
her hair is so pretty so that's why I
always ask Spirit to give these little
things that nobody else would know but
you and I have to say this because when
I walked in the building earlier
I need to talk about this very tragic
departure and I want everyone to know
and anyone that does not know me or has
never heard of me maybe before because
you guys didn't know that I was going to
be here today correct
so what happens is the souls will bring
me through their passing so I will feel
what they felt as the soul left the
physical body so there had to be
something with the neck and or choking
because there's a restriction to the
throat but I can feel the blood like
almost like dripping down my neck so
that had to be some type of tragic
accident or the way that they departed
whether they actually were restricted
from the I'm trying to be very delicate
here it was the marking or something
with the neck do we understand the
tragedy over here
okay because I'm being I'm you have to
understand I'm just feeling this so we
don't have to talk about anything how do
you connect with either a handprint or a
thumbprint
I wouldn't say specifically that um I
had a very close friend pass away very
tragically and unexpectedly about a
month ago okay
um it was more choking okay but it was
here you have to understand I can't have
down time there are literally 12 Souls
standing in front of me show me that
they will they are taking responsibility
for their departure yeah so they will
just bring me through the passings so
for a soul to get me to come through and
to say something like that a validates
that the soul is at peace but more
importantly safe with God no matter how
they left the physical world who was
actually cremated
oh my goodness
he was okay and are you having a
difficult time with that or because some
people might feel because when a soul
what they do is when they step forward
in it all dress and then they spin
around and they come out in like casual
wear it's my symbol for that they
support on how they were chose to lay to
rest please don't judge me for saying
this but they don't care what we do with
their physical body that is for us
because they are not a part of it so
know that even though they were laid to
rest differently absolutely the soul is
at peace and wanting to thank the family
for that do you understand that oh yeah
how do you connect with football or
something with sports he worked with the
NFL for a little bit shut up I know this
is crazy I was not expecting it was this
morning did you think like uh like no
someone famous was coming in today
didn't think I'd be crying on national
television that's for sure what a way to
validate that the soul is at peace
[Music]
okay